hello I am Dr arat sahu associate
professor Department of CSC IIT guati
your instructor for this transformative
cloud and devops program brought to you
by simply learn in Partnership withan
ICT Academy I ghati at the master
instructor and part of the en ICT
Academy I guti I am thrilled to welcome
you to this course this program is
designed to offer a blend of theory and
practice arming you with a deep
understanding of cloud competing and
devop services you will have the
opportunity to work on over 40 handson
Projects and choose from three industry
oriented Capstone project on Microsoft
aure or AWS this enhances your practical
skills and enable you to tackle industry
relevant problems through an imip
learning experience you'll get to work
with 20 plus devops tools and cloud
services sharpening your skills in our
integrated sandbox Labs simply learn
will also help you transition smoothly
into the industry by offering resum
assistance interview preparations and
more Edge part of BS job assist program
completing the program will fetch you a
digital and physical hard copy
certificate from En ICT Academy I guati
throughout this journey you will attend
live virtual classes led by Sean
industry experts and outstanding Academy
sces together we will bring our
extensive experience and insights to you
with a unique plan of theoretical and
applied learning I am confident this
program will be a transformative steps
towards building a successful career in
the repeat evolving field of cloud and
devops thank you for choosing this
course and I wish you all the best